all righty Kip uses example I say you
can white finish black you said black
people are less intelligent than white
people as a result of their results on
the IQ tests as a collective group and
that's that's that's indicative of a
genetic go to guru today please please
calm down please
just let you keep laughing but I just
wanna you saying that it's problematic
on account of the following IQ tests
themselves are not compliant with the
scientific method let me explain to you
the IQ test itself is a configuration
which is susceptible to human critique
and/or amendment well wrong correct
therefore using it as an exact measure
for PMON intelligence currently as a
current measure is unjustifiable
especially considering let me let me
explain let me explain especially
considering excuse me especially
considering that those who constructed
the IQ test themselves were people who
might have had biases well we have let
me give an example I mean I may have an
example right and this is not something
this let me give an example is
bilingualism
or multilingualism included in the IQ
test my question is it included yes or
no no no it's no it's not now
yes here's the point do black people do
let me ask a question do black people
have a higher or lesser chance of being
bilingual or multilingual than a white
man please please please I'll ask it a
question does a black man in Africa have
a higher or lesser chance of being
bilingual or multilingual than a white
man in Europe
no it's not equal no it's not you know
why no it's not okay Ralph you Ralph is
more equal and not one sorry Ralph sorry
I'm sorry I apologize I apologize I'm
sorry let's let's be specific let's be
specific
again the Western European example
Western Europe I'm going to be very
specific I'm talking about this colonial
narrative of especially Western Europe
okay and I think you have to understand
something brother
yeah you have to really understand side
these you know these eugenics programs
that they did and in what you call it in
Germany yeah where they brand it they
had you know that the supreme race the
white man with the blue eyes and so on
and this is the you know the ideal the
women so she would know she would know
she would know so she would know what
her parents are poor forefathers in fact
there would have been there would have
been part of this right so that the idea
of the the idea of the white man with
the blue ice the white man with the blue
eyes being the the apex balls and the
boogey man that scares you their points
not completed my sentence oh yeah right
I'm not saying that just because it's
provided a justification I'm saying that
this I'm not making that point I could
say that
Ralph sorry I could have made the point
I said I'm not gonna be more emotive
sanctimonious and say well that's how
they justified the burning of the
Ashkenazi Jews you you said all the
highest IQ and it was ironic you tell me
but but just let me say my first the
point is the the inherent biases in
those scientific practices from German
scientists
reflected upon subsequent subsequent
results of so-called scientific
discoveries so therefore you have to
understand number one how science can be
very biased because you have a lungful
you really need to like take a minute
let me help someone so summarize what
your so let me summarize it give me one
minute just one minute
and then you can talk for two minutes I
put up one minute okay
to summarize you're right science itself
can be used by racist people and then
those racist people can then use the
word data to make it seem as if science
has this is a legitimate racism now
moving on to social sciences which is
even weaker it's more feeble than
science yes because it attempts to mimic
it it's a cheap copy
it's a pseudoscience according to Karl
Popper sure and then the resulting
placement tests which are called IQ
tests which are put in place to try and
measure people's intelligence
collectivise them and then justify
further racism which is what your
phase-two might be if not for you but
someone else would say it's phase 2 of
the program the point not it's not
finished
so you have to justify why the
parameters included in the IQ test are
the the best possible parameters when
they don't include those things which
black people or people of color would
have this advantage would have as
advantages over and above white people
and do link and other and do link to
intelligence according to a majority of
studies that have been done on it so
that can you answer that question so let
me know you get about 20 minutes one
minute yeah
before the
I let me start by produced popper and
your question the scientific method
requesting basically Western
civilization which is with some brand
you're standing on let me tell you about
Western civilization so in the end is
what you're referring to loosely as
logical positivism and Wittgenstein and
pauper down the room and everyone else
this was still 40 years before the
invention in computer science we see
people at myself as two types of chimps
in this world those who get theoretical
computer science and those that don't
the scientific method is just an
algorithm it's a class backwards not
alternative hypotheses are algorithms
wrong the type on that your errors are
algorithms methodological it depends on
algorithm as large composite is an
algorithm the Trinity we style and the
pauper give me the Trinity we spiral
that populated with three world world
there are three worlds one is a physical
world which I will measure using science
and computer science as the time the
universe fifteen billion years plus our
space-time continuum for human eyes
chimps in a data point time T then I
would look at evolution she stopped uh
performing computational science for
this abstraction World War two is
measured by conscious creatures in it
you and I as to terms and those at
processing that was that Trinity that
creates us tells us that from a gene to
itself bring me to sell to sell to chimp
she about to get twenty thousand I
forced you into your saliva using forty
register your saliva in twenty-three
your chin down twenty thousand
I'll see you Mohammad Javad is twenty
thousand on the bow see which tribe you
came from down from Baghdad for Maui I
will find every temple and I will see
your propensity with diabetes for motor
neuron disease for heart I would look
for using medicine algebra tremor when
you're in a space about this way that
this is the data immunological regions
you say racism because obviously you
will have to form allies with the left
while yes term
yeah okay so in that Christian Western
science in that Christian we have data
I'm going to look at the data and racism
and some left-wing quite a white light
from our racist and Mahalo doesn't
interest me
I apologize queue of racism I told you
today I'm not going to be morally
sanctimonious I'll let that for other
people to talk about right and I haven't
accused you of racism by the way racism
is a neutral term hold on hold on why I
mean by racism being a neutral term it
doesn't have to be necessarily
derogatory depending on how you define
it and how its expressed racism sorry
racism is just an expression of a
collective of group a collective
referring themselves referring to
themselves so self identifying or being
referred to as watching I referring to
themselves being self-identified or
being referred to as others as say for
instance black or Y or ever being
oppressed through power relations or
otherwise by other people and all being
discriminated against
now that could have undertones which are
political but it could also be something
which is neutrally used my question to
you which you couldn't answer you tried
talking about algorithms with what the
fact no no no is the fact that how can
you justify making them my questions how
can you justify I haven't finished my
question how can you justify making
overarching generalizations about
intelligence when the systems and
methods hollow the systems and methods
by which involve an acuity the end Ralph
by the way I did let you speak okay
our changes are not working or performed
equally another you're not on the oh
you're you're thinking in a linear way
okay checked it you're thinking a value
it's not objective no I've not told you
about my emotion so you're talking about
something else now have I said I feel
this way already you seem to love them
well I don't know I didn't say this
though I say that everyone seemed like
no no no I'm not saying I like you I'm
not talking about you now what I'm
saying is this my claim is very so him
rough you expect me to say certain
things because you hear that from the
left I'm not left wing guy hold on I'm
not no identifiers with the left all the
way I don't know I don't believe so yeah
although I really genuinely don't
believe so I disagree with that
completely yeah but what I was gonna say
was this yeah no and we're not left all
right we don't go in your your spectrum
your political spectrum we don't have to
fit nicely with it yeah yeah yeah so
what I was gonna say was this yeah was
the point I was making you keep using
words like data and objective truths and
emotions no it's no no it's an easy it's
an easy argument to win against someone
who doesn't know what they're talking
about but if you're talking to someone
who's done Social Sciences and I spent
many years doing so like myself and I
tell you now it's magic no no no I'm not
to be funny but no not to be funny but
I've got the credentials from those guys
that you take us I do have those
credentials if you want to show them to
you as well but even even if we don't
talk about that and I said you look the
issue is this the issue is that you're
using a measure which is a byproduct
listen to me carefully
it's a but it's a by-product of a of a
social science that was done from
usually you're not listening to my you
know listening to my objection they say
but the IQ test is not cannot be seen as
an incorrigible test that is that is
incapable of being amended in the future
you can assume excuse me tonight before
I have a finish
and moreover and moreover therefore to
categorize races as as a result of their
performances on IQ tests when for
knowing full well that within the
parameters of IQ test certain things
like bilingualism and multilingualism is
not included which I really you're not
you're not you're not listening you're
simply not listening I will say to you
I'm gonna make a statement right now
yeah I'm gonna say to you that people
that can speak two languages are
cleverer in my eyes than people that
could speak one okay
yes colonial people that have been
colonized by the West and others because
in 1914 according to one of your great
scholars his name was homi Bhabha I'm
not sure you've heard of it yeah yeah is
there post-colonial think of it tonight
85% of people 85% of the world was
colonized by a few European countries
eighty-five percent a lot of people have
colonial amnesia
you have colonial amnesia you know
unremember one thing is not you have
because you don't know the extent to
which colonial powers that are have
affected educational systems of
measuring intelligence and giving
intelligence so that so that so that
compartmentalization collectivization
and then exploitation can be continued
in the post-colonial narrative now
here's the point that's why they do it
now I'm saying to you something very
simply that in Western Europe the people
that were meant to see as the Superman
the you know the Superman with a blue
eyes and the white skin
sorry that the Indonesian word the
ubermensch at the ubermensch those
individuals were meant to be the apex
yet those individuals who are meant to
be the apex of human civilization
because of their schools and IQ tests
which have been rigged so that they can
be the IQ test can be rewritten a high
you feel this summer no no I can
summarize your words into anything no I
mean summarize your board you would help
IQ chess I'm not I'm not falling for
that I'm not
for that trap I'm not [__] over so
that Ralph will you take an IQ test
livestreaming what will you take I don't
believe an IQ test you don't listen to
argument ok now go away don't talk about
IQ test I've done enough just in this
country for ten years so yeah Wow Wow
the point is this if I if you can take
if you if you agree with me that people
that know more than one language on if
everything staying the same would be
more intelligent than person over one
language the question I asked what a
question I asked is why have why has the
elitist Westerners not put language
ability in the IQ test because you know
why do you know why the answer is never
say the reasons the reason why price
today the reason why is because black
people are going to go higher off in
that test and Ashkenazim Jews are going
to go down yeah
goodbye thank you very much thank you
thank you very much Bob thank you thank
you
well dunno